hi I'm Erik Bosse and Captain Marvel
just dropped a new trailer that finally
shows us what brings a smile to carol
danvers face going super saiyan the
blown up a bunch of stuff in space by
the way can we lay off brie Larson's
facial acting she's got gross bluish
blood on it that's never fun
let's break down this trailer frame by
frame for all the interesting details
that you might have missed it's more
than warning in case any of the
predictions I'm making it being right I
actually think I might be onto something
really crazy in this and if it ends up
being right I don't want you to blame me
for not warning you so warning okay
let's get started
so Scrolls are the bad guys
okay this trailer opens man returning to
the standout moment from the first
trailer Carol Danvers elder abuse like I
don't care what kind of subway dancer
parkour this whole lady does after you
just know that some of these commuters
are like that young woman in armor just
assaulted a very durable grandma during
this fight voiceover from Nick Fury
explains the whole setup two alien races
Kree and scroll they're at war earth is
ended up in the middle of it and the
scroll are shapeshifters and this
trailer confirms that this old woman is
indeed a scroll impostor actually pay
close attention you can hear this woman
growl after being hit and of course the
metal pole dance after she runs into it
suggests she's super strong by the way
this is all taking place in mid-90s Los
Angeles a train that's from Lee then
recently completed LA metro lines let's
move on and you're free a race of noble
warriors heroes noble warrior heroes
[Music]
here the conversation continues over a
shot of Carole boarding the Train look
closely the roof there apparently
someone smashed through it so that's how
all the holes in la's trains got there
think they would have fixed him I now AM
say young Nick Fury and Carole in the
car where Carole identifies as a Kree
the good guys in this galactic conflict
listen how absolute her tone is heroes
noble warrior heroes I don't know to me
this sounds like the kind of bold
declaration that a character makes in
the first acts of a movie just to have
it completely upended later on like we
know from the comics that the Kree
aren't exactly that noble they're pretty
cold-hearted and militaristic really
just a shade less crappy than the
scroller so this little smile here along
with Carroll's heroic swagger that we
see as she walks up with her Star Force
guys I think this will be the major
thing that changes throughout Carole's
arc in this movie by the way just
reminding the Star Force is kind of like
the Kree SEAL team 6
it includes Carol who actually goes by
verse on this Kree homeworld of hala
there's also Korath Djimon Honsou his
character from the guardians of the
galaxy this is long before he gets
radicalized and splits off with Ronan
the accuser who's also in this movie you
can also see Minerva that's Jim its
hands character she's a Kree geneticist
Atlas captain atlas in the comics he's
played by aldress Perez Soto and bran
char played by
Runa temptin let's move on your life
began the day it nearly ended we found
you
with no memory we made you one of us so
you could live longer stronger superior
okay this section is probably the most
mysterious that we've seen from this
movie yet
so we're introduced to Annette benning's
character she's an important Cree figure
who explains to carol how she came to
join them she says that they found her
when she was nearly dead and that she
had no memory and that they rebuilt hers
that she can live longer stronger and
superior but here's the thing
anyone who actually describes their race
with the word superior is probably an
a-hole and her words are also super
confusing because they kind of
contradict the imagery that we see like
if we're to assume that the Kree saved
Carol Danvers from this freak accident
later infusing her with this Bluegreen
Kree blood to heal her injuries why does
she appear to already have this bluish
greenish blood coming from her nose at
the crash site the moment that she gets
exposed to this alien tech also briefly
you can see a figure in green creek
armor walking up to Carol as she lies in
the dirt I suspect this is Jude Law's
character whose name Marvel still has
yet to release to us we had first
thought that who's playing Marvel that's
Carol Danvers Kree predecessor who gave
her her powers but all the secrecy
around his name has led to speculation
that it could be gone rogue captain
Marvel's recurring nemesis from the
comics also notice this place where
Carol and Annette Benitez character are
standing it's some vast room with
interesting lights and holographic
shapes shining all around it this movie
Captain Marvel it's clearly all about
memories I'm thinking this could be some
kind of memory recreation chamber
something like Tony Stark's barf
technology and like Barth I think we
should remember that these memories are
not objective reality they can be
subjective false memories I'm just
saying we shouldn't trust benning's
character 100% and I'll actually piece
together my theory for how I think
everything went down in just a bit but
in fairness we should say this Kree lady
does give us one clear answer to a
question that we've had notice how she
says Carol will live longer
that explains why Carol's aging process
is so slow like why she appears to be
the same age when she returns to earth
and why she will probably look the same
in the present day in the
Avengers movie and after verse fires
energy blasts from her fists as a member
of the Star Force we move on to the next
clip Guillory for I keep having these
memories something in my past is the key
to all of this
here we see this same shot of Carole
upside down it was on the last trailer
but now a wider anger reveals a scroll
on the far left now this is interesting
before I speculated that this could be
Carole having Pulse memories implanted
in her mind by the creek but now I'm
thinking that she's with the scroll and
they're trying to extract memories from
her mind like maybe that is how Talos
seems to know her origin like he pin
sieved this fractured memory from her
mind and he reassembled it into a clear
narrative for everyone to understand
perhaps Carole surrenders some to the
scrolls that they could help her out
this way like she's playing both sides
really I think this is going to be the
big drive for Carole in the movie the
piece together her past and
distinguished between which memories
seem real and which could have been
implanted by the Kree to reprogram her
into a super-soldier interesting detail
here look closely these memory flashes
little girl Carole is lying beside
someone in a striped shirt and that same
shirt is on the person go-kart racing
with her when she's a bit older this
could be her father who has very limited
shirts or this could be a kind of matrix
II implanted memory man but instead of
the woman in the red dress it's the man
in the striped shirt now another memory
features Carole as a pilot flashing the
sign to her friend maria rambo callsign
photon she is actually the mother of
Monica Rambeau from the Marvel Comics
Monaco goes with a hero named Photon
she also actually takes on the Captain
Marvel mantle herself at one point now
Carole's patch here says the United
States Air Force test pilot school
that's located at Edwards Air Force Base
in the desert in Southern California
it's actually where the Air Force tests
out experimental aerospace tech I'm
thinking Carole and Maria are testing
out some new secret Air Force tech and
that could be what leads to Carol's
run-in with the Kree and her whole
accident we also see more of Carol's
foot chase with that scroll on the train
here's she blossomed and right before he
gets lit up you can see him in red
ducking under the train tunnel
I assume this is right before he turns
into that sweet old lady let's move on
you're not a bad thing we'll see
that's a yes or no question yes okay and
this section Nick Fury and Carol Danvers
visit some military hangar but these
jets look kind of crazy and techie Yuri
is clearly shocked that Carol knows how
to operate this jet and when it flies
out of the hangar look closely that
looks like the 90s prototype twin jet an
early model of the one that the Avengers
later use but also check out the hole
that it flies out of whatever that is
that's gotta be super-secret like most
air bases are located on flat terrain
like they don't require pilots to land
in and take off from bat cave style
cliffside entrances this theory has come
up before but I'm thinking this could be
area 51 or like some fictional version
of it like maybe fury takes Carol here
to try to learn about her past as an Air
Force test pilot and while she's there
she recognizes classified aircraft
that's parked there and if you look
closely at the controls on the dash you
can actually see its previous heading
speed and altitude its heading or
compass direction is twenty point six
degrees meaning that the jet was flying
north-northeast and it was traveling
roughly the cruising speed and altitude
of commercial jetliner does this tell us
anything about what happened to Carol
well not yet
you just wait these stats are gonna come
in handy next clip would you like to
know
what you really are
I think I had a life here
what are you telling me okay here we
start with this shot of three alien
warships now I actually think these are
scroll because it's actually the same
shot it's one that we saw earlier where
a Kree ship was speeding down to that
planet's surface and actually see that
same ship now in this shot it's a tiny
dot closer to the surface
perhaps it's being chased by these
scroll ships and next we severs with her
Kree helmet fading off her face and it
lets her mohawk ponytail fall down so
whoo awesome this technology actually
looks almost exactly like the kind of
tech that Star Lord Peter quill uses to
activate and take off his mask I'm
thinking that he's using Kree tech for
that also look at the wall behind Carol
here looks like there's some bluish
greenish blood splattered on it Carol
may be walking into a Kree blood bath
here now this section also takes us back
to that cryptic crash site memory again
the imagery is super crazy this shot of
the explosion has a strange lens flare
you look closely you can see hexagonal
or maybe there are pentagonal shapes
they're lit up almost as if this could
be a projected memory from those lights
that we saw back in annette bening x'
room there's a lot more bluish greenish
blood which again shouldn't be there if
carol hasn't been infused with Kree
blood yet and there's this mysterious
silhouette figure coming through the
smoke Carol gazes at it confused and
then it appears to be a scroll attacking
her look of love but remember earlier
there was that other angle of the scene
but taken out of Carol's point of view
it depicted this figure as a green Kree
armored figure so here is what I think
is going on I think US Air Force pilot
Carol Danvers broke formation upon
seeing a UFO and she chased it down and
she got mixed up in a Kree Skrull
dogfight chins up crashing and she gets
exposed to some radiation that gives her
powers maybe this was from some weapon
or technology that the two sides were
fighting over the Kree dude lost
character sees this and then they decide
to recruit kidnap Carol and use her as a
super soldier they wipe her memory and
then replace it with false memories
memories that demonized the Skrull make
her hate the scroll make her really good
at killing the scroll it's kind of like
that episode a black mirror where
soldiers are a program to see certain
people as monsters that could explain
why these various shots of the crash
site have these inconsistencies
I think this memory is going to be key
to
movie if a feeling Carroll's gonna
revisit it over and over and over again
it's a crucial formative moment and
she's gonna try to piece together the
mystery here with all the details in the
memory changing because many of them
could have been implanted fake ones I
think ultimately Carol is gonna figure
out this conspiracy by looking at old
classified records of her time as a test
pilot and maybe my talking with the
scroll ultimately leading to her refusal
to fight in the kree-skrull war anymore
instead to end it to keep earth out of
this war one detail here notice that
when she goes through her belongings
there's her old dog tag and it's been
broken in half right at Carol dad with
the other half presumably having burrs
on it yagi RS that's the origin of her
Kree name I suppose this is a Marvel
version of Marty McFly's mom thinking
his name's Calvin Klein because it's
written on his underwear let's move on
to come a long way but you know as
strong as you think
the small cysts the beginning
I'm not gonna fight your war in this
section we see more memory flash
montages that we saw in the first
trailer with parallel moans from Carol's
life syncing up all the moment she fell
all the moment she dusted herself off
and got back to her feet actually when
she falls off the bike look at those
cars behind her VW bus the others look
like models from the late 60s early 70s
this would establish Carol's
disappearance in the mid to late 80s and
her time away from Earth is about a
decade Jude Law's character lectures her
back on Halle and he could see that one
of those Kree infusion ports from her
arm and we saw earlier it's also on her
neck perhaps this is a place that they
upload those false memories it's kind of
like the plugs that they use in the
matrix we also see Carol and her new red
and blue suit which I assume that she
takes on after breaking away from her
cream oil teas the facility that she's
in busting up must be controlled by
humans like notice that foosball table
broken there I think the guys that she's
taking out our shield soldiers they're
dressed in that old-school black uniform
that we saw in concept art for the
shield soldiers we get a new close-up of
Talos with the voice of Ben Mendelsohn
that we've been hearing throughout the
trailer along with a shot of Ronan from
guardians of the galaxy observing a
space battle and then we see Talos his
human form leading a group of agents
into that hangar that we saw earlier now
Talos works for shield meaning that the
agency has been compromised by scrol
imposters suggesting that this story
might be Nick Fury's first rodeo with
shield being overtaken by a hostile
influence this event preparing him for
when he and cap battle with Hydra and
Winter Soldier on to the next clip I'm
gonna end it
[Music]
here we see Carol in her full glory now
this is called binary in the comics
Captain Marvel taps into the power of a
white hole it's basically the
theoretical opposite of a black hole
rather than energy and matter going into
it infinite amounts of energy and matter
beam out of it that's why this blinding
white light emits from Carol's body this
is why you keep hearing that Captain
Marvel is the most powerful Marvel hero
the ability to go binary mixer more
powerful maybe then danos through the
hole though we should say that in
various incarnations of the comics their
powers are relative depending on the
situation so that doesn't mean that
Captain Marvel can just like punch
Stannis and balls and be done with it oh
I think it's gonna be a pretty big help
listen to Carol declare her intention
I'm not gonna fight your war I'm gonna
end it to me this line resonates with
the Avengers storyline one it sets up
Captain Marvel as a hero who ends wars
maybe even infinity once but also this
might answer that question of why Nick
Fury refused to call Captain Marvel for
so long like I've been wondering what
sacrifice Carol Danvers would have had
to make for fury to grant her privacy
and retirement from superheroing maybe
10 years of murdering Scrolls for a Kree
Empire that brainwashed her was enough
manipulation for a lifetime so perhaps
out of pity fury leaves her with this
pager and says only if the universe
depends on it and of course we know it's
gonna depend on her okay onto this last
bit what's your name
it turns out Fury's a cat person notice
the name tag is now this most likely a
reference by Carroll to the movie Top
Gun which would maybe be the favorite
movie of 80s pilot Carol Danvers goose
was Mavericks buddy
and he ties I think that dark turn could
be foreshadowing an interesting twist
for goose the cat here you see in the
comics Carroll's cat is named chewy and
it turns out he's not even a cat rocket
racoon points out that he's actually an
alien race called a Fleur kid which
connection teleport stuff with little
pocket dimensions that they carry yeah
they're kind of weird
and notice how goose paws down Fury's
hand away from his collar maybe that's
not a cute little kitty cuddle it's
actually a well-trained animal actor
communicating hey hands off the merch
I'm just saying guys we know this is a
movie that we will learn the mystery of
how Nick Fury lost his eye and roll my
favorite clip last time I trusted
someone I lost an eye yeah and I have
never seen Nick Fury trust anyone as
much as he trusts this little kitty cat
so you just wait goose is gonna claw
that eye out that scratch injury kind of
looks like kitty scratches to me here's
my question for you guys
assuming that some of Carole's memories
are false which of these memories do you
think are real and which do you think
could be implanted are they all fake
coming down below with your thoughts and
follow new rock stars on twitter and
instagram at new rock stars and feel
like me you can follow me on twitter and
instagram at a boss subscribe to this
channel for these kinds of in-depth
breakdowns of everything Avengers
related news theories trailers we get
pretty obsessed here I guess I've always
been this way you know even as a kid
wait oh that that memory was implanted I
am a mess
[Music]